Justin here with another GameSpot news
update did you use exploits to trying to
get rich quick in The Witcher 3 the
hearts of stone expansion might have
some punishment in store for you
developer CD Projekt RED has already
addressed the witcher 3 wild plants
infinite money exploits involving cow
hides and pearls but now players who
benefited from the get-rich-quick scheme
are being approached by a local tax man
who wants them to pay up youtube channel
what's my game posted a video that
highlights the encounter during the main
hearts of stone mission
the deputy tax enumerator from the
Revenue & Customs Department approaches
you to discuss a hides and pearls tax
he'll ask you the following questions
have you at any time engaged in the
wholesale trade of rawhide in the white
orchard area during the current fiscal
year have you engage from the
acquisition of bivalves with the express
intention of selling the pearls therein
the tax man even cites a specific statue
it whoever purchases goods at an
unseemly low price to take advantage of
the sellers ignorance shall be subject
to a fine equaling 200% of the earnings
from any such transaction are you
engaged in any illegal rawhide trade I
know at least one of us is here in game
spot to find out who stay tuned to
games.com